all right we've got a little bit of wind
out there sometimes it gets stronger
than others right now the palm tree
looks pretty quiet out there on the west
side
temperatures have cooled off to the 60s
in far west valley neighborhoods all the
way from mountains edge
out to summerlin to centennial hills
even the lakes is
68 right now the rest of the valley
pretty much sitting in the low 70s
we'll have those winds up and down
through the day up to about 25 maybe
even 30 miles an hour
as a front it's a stationary front just
kind of sitting to the north of us look
at all those clouds they've lifted away
we've got great sunshine
wind advisories come back tomorrow for
lincoln county
western clark and southern nye counties
as the winds will get stronger
as that front slides our way even high
wind watches
for central and northern nye county as
well as inyo county
over into california we still have red
flag warnings still very very dry and
with these gusty winds
that keeps the fire danger very elevated
for us so please
be careful with anything that could
spark and get a fire started it would
get out of control in these winds
so we'll keep the winds look at the
temperatures though yesterday 96 today
94
tomorrow 95 and then behind that front
we're even dropping to
90 degrees there'll be some
neighborhoods don't get out of the 80s
on thursday
but prepare yourself because just within
48 hours
temperatures take off we're back to 105
108 for your weekend even up to
10 next week and i think that number
will stick
for a while